INTERVIEWER: All right, as
we have people settling in,
let's get it started
with a bang, bang.
BENNY DAYAL: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: Welcome
to Google [? Pro ?].
We are really excited
to have you here.
I don't think Benny
Dayal really needs
any introduction in Bollywood.
You have songs for
Blockbuster movies,
some songs for my favorite
actor [INAUDIBLE].
That's such an amazing song.
It's great.
Song for the
[? Thick Russian ?] like
the song for the
[? Thick Russian ?]
"Bang Bang".
The [? Bailors ?] that's
their favorite song.
Like, his dance and your
song like, so, so good.
Song for two States, Race two
[? Japanese ?] [INAUDIBLE]
and the list keeps going on.
And I'm not even
talking about the movies
down in South [INAUDIBLE].
You continue to
amaze me, brother.
You're, after the [INAUDIBLE] I
see you as the new [? Hamid. ?]
This is amazing.
Hats off.
So, Benny, what really
brings you to Bay Area?
BENNY DAYAL: I have
a concert tomorrrow.
INTERVIEWER: Tell us
something about your concert.
BENNY DAYAL: It's basically,
the concert is called Bang Bang
and it's put on by
[INAUDIBLE] and my manager.
So they've probably done
[INAUDIBLE] the founding
of my band FunktuaTion.
This is my band.
INTERVIEWER: Guys, a big round
of applause for the band.
BENNY DAYAL: So we actually
started out as a fun solo--
not the-- just producing
our own fan music
and playing a lot of covers.
And then eventually
things started
getting really busy
for me as an artist.
And I asked them, is it OK
to play Bollywood music also?
And they were like, but how?
And I was like, just
the way we make music,
nothing exactly like Bollywood.
It needs to be improvised.
It needs to be the
way we feel like it.
And everybody was on board
and I really thank them.
Because of them we had to-- ever
since they've come on board,
we go all of the
world and everybody's
been interested in our
sound and [INAUDIBLE]
INTERVIEWER: That's amazing.
So I have a question.
Is this the same band that was
part of the song "Bang Bang?"
BENNY DAYAL: No,
no, no. "Bang Bang,"
those are pretty--
we did our own rehash
video of "Bang Bang."
INTERVIEWER: I saw that.
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, yeah.
That is exactly them.
That's exactly them.
The songs are generally produced
by [? Mishar ?] [? Mashakur ?].
So that's what you
hear in the movie.
But then we create
our own versions.
INTERVIEWER: I loved
your version, man.
BENNY DAYAL: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: It was awesome.
You guys, check out on YouTube.
Benny's band has done
a "Bang Bang" cover
and it's really amazing.
BENNY DAYAL: We
actually shot the video
in all of the hotel rooms that
we've stayed in when we travel.
So we're just keeping it
very real and very intimate.
And it was amazing because
the kind of response we got,
not only from just fans but from
the industry, was unbelievable.
Like including the [? shot ?]
[? that ?] and [? Shakur ?]
himself was like so impressed
with the production.
And we have to thank
Doby our engineer.
He's not here.
He'll be in the Bay Area
by noon I'm supposing.
So Doby was behind shooting and
recording all of us in August.
We shot and recorded
the stuff in Delhi
and others in Bombay,
Banglor, and Bangladesh,
stuff like that.
Because we were
traveling very constantly
and we also shot it from the
footage in our concerts--
biggest live concerts and
also [INAUDIBLE] the shots.
We actually recorded some
of the percussion stuff.
Allen is on persucssion.
So Allen recorded some
of the percussion stuff
inside using the
bathroom acoustics.
So, no, it was
really interesting.
It's really interesting
because it's
all about sound at the end
of the day and we actually--
INTERVIEWER: You were playing
percussion in the bathroom?
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, in
the bathroom, yeah.
INTERVIEWER: Who
gave you that idea?
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah,
it was-- no, no it
was a great area because
the capture was really clean
and it was really nice.
A very interesting idea.
INTERVIEWER: I've actually
tried singing in an empty hall
sometimes and some
people like some of it.
They really, really like it.
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah,
empty definitely.
But when it is
filled with people
also it sounds even better.
Because first it's
too empty and then
when an audience come to
a place to watch a concert
it's when they absorb
the sound properly.
Like, you guys that are
actually absorbing the sound
and it just sounds
perfect after that.
So yeah.
INTERVIEWER: Great.
So I assume [INAUDIBLE]
was still here?
BENNY DAYAL: Indeed.
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
"Bang Bang" really.
So there is a-- did you
always thought of becoming
a singer from a very young age?
BENNY DAYAL: Yes.
I only wanted to
become a musician.
INTERVIEWER: Family was singer?
BENNY DAYAL: No.
My mother's a dancer.
I learned and did classical
dance for 14 years so
that's how it I became so
inclined to performing arts.
And yeah, it's-- yes, since the
age of 13 I wanted to become
a singer.
INTERVIEWER: And did you
undergo any classical training?
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, I've done
[INAUDIBLE] music as a kid.
And that had taught me
some beautiful things.
INTERVIEWER: And
how did you really
make it to Bollywood, man?
There are so many singers that
crave for making to Bollywood.
BENNY DAYAL: Well, I must thank
Mr. [? Armaan ?] for, you know,
I didn't define my talent.
He has been the
reason why I wanted
to become a muscian also.
Because when he
started making music,
we started to listening to
new, new singles every time.
And to be very honest, that
was the time when he came out
in '90s-- was the time when we
were at a point in India where,
what?
You want to become a singer?
Like, go get a job.
That's what people are saying.
They're like, become a
manager at some company
and get married and have so many
kids and give up your pension.
That's exactly what they wanted.
INTERVIEWER: Big family, really?
BENNY DAYAL: I became socially--
[INAUDIBLE] Who knows?
That's exactly what I'm saying.
So someone like him actually
made us youngsters want
to take music as a profession.
And he's the one who opened
the eyes of the entire nation.
Even when I go abroad and I
see people who are supporting--
they have a normal job but then
they're supporting your concert
because they have so much
passion towards music.
And then one got a lot of guy
who was running around errands.
But then that [? errand ?] comes
in and says, I love to sing.
And what should I do
to become a singer?
So just follow the dream.
Don't stop.
INTERVIEWER: I agree with you.
Indian passion face.
If you're really
passionate, you are here.
BENNY DAYAL: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: So family
does support you?
Do you have full
support from family?
BENNY DAYAL: Not initially.
Not initially.
They were shocked.
My father was especially
shocked because--
INTERVIEWER: Fathers are not
who they may be [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: No, actually
that was the shock for me.
Because my dad was the most
supportive human being.
And then when I told
him I wanted to become
a musician, he was like, what?
And my mother's
like, yeah, why not?
And I didn't expect my
mother to even say anything.
Then eventually just [INAUDIBLE]
and I had to prove it to them
that I'm good.
INTERVIEWER: You're really
good with bell, man.
Like, so awesome.
[SPEAKING OTHER LANGUAGE]
So who is your favorite singer
that you love listening to
and still love to listen.
[NON-ENGLISH]
INTERVIEWER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
BENNY DAYAL: I don't
know about that.
I love [INAUDIBLE] I
don't try to imitate her.
But I try and not upset her.
INTERVIEWER: That's
likely the best.
That's where a
lot of people say.
To artists [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
BENNY DAYAL:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
That's most important thing.
INTERVIEWER: So how has been
your experience working with
[INAUDIBLE] [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
BENNY DAYAL: Even,
actually, I still
don't have a picture with
[INAUDIBLE] To be very honest.
My brother [? Nazeef ?] has more
pictures with him than I do.
This my chance to
pick [? his case ?]
in a public forum.
But, yeah, I'm very
glad I worked with him.
Because I must say,
that we youngsters,
whoever has worked with him, are
very, very lucky to be alive,
to be listening to
his music, and to have
worked with him above all in
the era when Mr. A.R. Rahman is
alive.
It's a true blessing.
There's nothing beyond
that for any artist
because, even if you meet
any singer or any musician,
they say that.
I was [? there ?] [? too. ?]
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: He's an
amazing human being.
I just can't explain.
You can't explain that, right?
It's very hard.
I just want to say that
I'm so thankful to God
that it happened
and I work with him.
INTERVIEWER: Great to see, man
that you're [? successful ?]
It's really good.
And [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
BENNY DAYAL: You do
definitely get nervous
but then I think he somehow
eradicates that nervousness out
of you.
If you choose to still be
nervous, then it's on you.
Normally, you
shouldn't be nervous,
becuase this is the
opportunity, right?
When you are in front of him.
you try and do your best.
You try do your best for
anybody in that case.
But when you meet him--
he has that energy that
takes away all of your fear.
It just becomes
focused on the music.
And I like that
about [INAUDIBLE].
So does [INAUDIBLE].
Besides just singing
and working with him,
you really, really learn how
to be a good human being when
you meet him.
As for me, I wasn't such
a positive human being
when I-- before I met him.
Because I struggled through
so much to become a musician.
And I've had instances where
music directors have told me
that, have you got your voice?
And so yeah, know
what's wrong with it?
And he's like, you want
to become a singer?
You will not-- never
become a singer.
There were people
who've told me this,
you think you will
become a singer?
I don't think so.
[INAUDIBLE] There
are people like that.
And that I have somebody
like [? Rahman ?]
gives you an opportunity
and shows the world
what you're capable of.
And that's true magic.
And for me that's
exactly why I said--
I don't want to say anything
about it because he's
all about his music,
and he's spoken to you
through his music.
I want to say this one beautiful
thing, about [? Rahman ?] which
I have never told,
ever in my life,
and I can say it right now.
It's that,
[? Rahman ?] said that,
one of the greatest
crime of our time
that's to steal all
our hearts with music.
INTERVIEWER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
BENNY DAYAL: I don't do that.
As a child my heart was stolen
by him through his music.
So finally-- eventually work
with him-- it's just surreal.
INTERVIEWER: Amazing.
So you have been in Bollywood
for quite some time now.
What do you think
about today's music,
as compared to '60s and '70s?
BENNY DAYAL: Well, it's
supposed to evolve.
It's supposed to move forward.
And that's very important.
And so many music directors
have played that important role
in changing-- and
taking things forward.
Like when everything was
moving in one direction,
we had [INAUDIBLE]
[? Rahman ?] just changed
the entire soundscape of music.
And then followed by [INAUDIBLE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] You name
it.
And everybody is doing it.
And then they are changing a
little by little by little.
The Indian music industry
is a team-- we are a team.
We're a fraternity.
It's-- that's how we work.
We are proving it to
the world that Bollywood
is such a strong genre.
And we are so versatile
as an industry.
Today, even if you and even
if you're at the immigration
and they ask you, so
you're a musician?
So what music do you play?
Do you play Bollywood?
So I feel proud.
I feel really proud that I'm
a part of that industry, which
produces great music.
So, hats off to all the
musicians, all the singers,
all the instrumentalists, all
the engineers who mix the sound
and make it viable for
a universal audience.
That change is
very, very involved.
from '60s to '70s to right now.
And [INAUDIBLE].
INTERVIEWER: That's amazing.
So what's the latest
that you are working on?
If anything, you
can share with us?
BENNY DAYAL: I'm not
supposed to share.
Some extremely,
extremely interesting
projects coming in for you
within the end of this year
and the beginning of next year.
Which includes [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE]
and [? Bengali ?] and
lots of other work.
INTERVIEWER: Nice
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
You've been the
voice of [INAUDIBLE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
BENNY DAYAL:
[INAUDIBLE] I've not
sung for [? Shara Khan ?] yet.
I wish to sing
for him some time.
INTERVIEWER: Now
audience, quick questions,
you can have [INAUDIBLE]
Take it later.
DIVYA: Hi Benny.
Thank you for coming here.
My name is Divya.
"Bang Bang" is one
of my favorite songs.
And I can't stop dancing
to it. [INAUDIBLE]
So I wanted to ask you, which is
your favorite song that you've
sung?
And which is your
favorite song that you
like to dance to,
considering you have da--
you have danced for so long.
BENNY DAYAL: I'll
answer the last one.
The answer to the second
part of the question
is definitely "Bang Bang."
It's a song that I
really like to dance to.
And my favorite song
personally is [INAUDIBLE]
It's very close to my heart.
Because the first time
you walk into a studio
and you get startled by the fact
that [INAUDIBLE] sitting there.
It's enormous pressure.
And I think pressure-- I
realize that the pressure brings
the best out of me.
It surely did.
One [INAUDIBLE].
It gave me so many
special moments in life.
INTERVIEWER: It's one of my
favorite songs, by the way.
BENNY DAYAL: Actually
did that song sums up
everything in my
life, everything
that I've gotten in life whether
it is music or friends or love
or anything.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] I
just don't even know.
[INAUDIBLE] like a question
and an answer iteself.
INTERVIEWER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
MALE SPEAKER: I have a question.
Welcome to Google.
Congratulations you have really
carved a niche for yourself.
You have a very distinct style.
Like they say, if people start
living together for long,
they start looking alike.
And I just couldn't
help but see your band,
and everybody looks alike.
Everybody looks like Benny
One, Benny Two, Benny Three.
Is it because you have
lived for long together?
BENNY DAYAL: No, no.
MALE SPEAKER: Or you are family?
BENNY DAYAL: We all
have individual lives.
I'll tell you something.
It's because it's the music.
It's the music.
If you look at all
of us, we actually
wear what we listen to.
It's the music that
speaks through us.
And it grooms us, too.
Music is such a beautiful thing.
It teaches you about life.
Teaches you how to be humble.
Teaches you how to be arrogant.
Teaches you how to be
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
It really, really teaches
you how to live your life.
And brings in lots of beautiful
principles in your life.
It grooms you as a human being.
And makes you-- puts you-- music
is quite a lot of discipline.
And we wouldn't
be playing the way
we play without any
amount of discipline
that each individual has put
in to the art of musicianship,
as they were growing up.
We watch a lot of music.
We have a lot of influences.
And we quite a lot of
time-- a lot of things
that we love from it.
We choose the best out of it.
We try inculcate
that into our life.
So that's exactly what you see.
And somehow you are
following the same category.
That's why we make
music together.
INTERVIEWER: Thanks so much.
That's a nice answer.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Hi Benny.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
Such a pleasure to have
you here, at Google.
I have to say, I love dancing,
and some of your songs
are my favorite
songs to dance to.
BENNY DAYAL: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: In
fact some of his songs
are my favorite songs to
listen to when I work out.
But let me tell you
the only song that
can make me run eight miles on
a treadmill, because as soon
as I have a playlist
and I've had them for,
I think a year and a half, but
[INAUDIBLE] is my permanent.
Other songs have come and gone.
And as soon as that song
comes on, I am on fire.
And the other songs like that,
[INAUDIBLE] huge fan, my dad
is a huge fan of yours, too.
BENNY DAYAL: Thank you.
Thank you so much, please
give him my regards.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah I
told my dad that I meet Benny
and he was like, oh
my god, say hi to him.
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Thank you,
Benny, you have made my day.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Hi, Benny.
How are you?
I think one of your songs
that I've always loved
is [INAUDIBLE] when
you sung it years ago.
When we were school.
BENNY DAYAL: [INAUDIBLE]
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Yes.
BENNY DAYAL: You're [INAUDIBLE]?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Yes,
BENNY DAYAL: Wow,
[INAUDIBLE] school.
You know, I'm just
starting to realize it.
I'm so different [INAUDIBLE]
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I think
I couldn't recognize it.
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was thinking, like, the smile
is, very, very recognizable.
And then I was like,
is this [INAUDIBLE]?
LIke, it's been running
in the back of my head.
[INAUDIBLE] is my [? junior. ?]
We danced and sang and competed
and everything I
should [INAUDIBLE].
What a small world.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
I don't work here.
This is my friend and my
husband also works here.
BENNY DAYAL: Oh, wow.
Nice meeting you.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: --I found
out that you're coming here.
INTERVIEWER: Any questions
from the audience since we
can take one from [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
questions [INAUDIBLE]
INTERVIEWER: OK, [INAUDIBLE].
BENNY DAYAL:
[INAUDIBLE] can I give?
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: We're
going to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So I've seen
[INAUDIBLE] seen you perform
[INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I saw
you dancing [INAUDIBLE].
So is that really [INAUDIBLE]
so much effort, right?
Like, a lot of people just
can't sing on the stage.
You are dancing, right?
And [INAUDIBLE] effortless.
So [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, I am, I am.
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] dancing.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
east of [INAUDIBLE].
videos again.
Your "Bang Bang" [INAUDIBLE].
So, [INAUDIBLE] dance
moves [INAUDIBLE].
BENNY DAYAL: Actually,
I was [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, I'm a
trained dancer, so [INAUDIBLE].
That's my classmate from school.
So, thank you for coming.
And yeah, so, yeah, I--
actually, in school,
everybody knew me as a
dancer, not as a singer,
except for [INAUDIBLE] parents.
AUDIENCE: You will
sing [INAUDIBLE].
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, and I used to
sing a lot of [INAUDIBLE] music
when I was in school.
So yeah, that's
what [INAUDIBLE].
But then dancing,
yeah, I actually
wanted to inculcate that
into me, into my career.
And it happened, as
I started performing,
everybody was like,
[INAUDIBLE], whoa, OK, fine.
So-- but then that's exactly
what I wanted to happen.
I wanted that impact on people.
And now slowly, it's growing
in the eyes of the people
and the audience and the fans.
Everybody gets to
see what I'm doing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
question [INAUDIBLE]
you can dance and sing.
Like, most of the singers in
Bollywood, they just sing.
[INAUDIBLE]
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, I
actually don't use much
of my [INAUDIBLE] performing.
You know, it's now
there in the system.
It's like muscle memory.
It's like you waking
up and you don't
forget to brush your teeth.
INTERVIEWER: We've got one
question for [INAUDIBLE] pass
on the mic, [INAUDIBLE].
Actually, this
girl's [INAUDIBLE]
in school. [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: And [? Mike ?] must
know that we did that as well.
As I understand it, you went
to school in the Middle East.
I also did go to school there.
But my question is, how did that
help you increase your talent
or hone your talent?
Does it-- you think it is
people from the Middle East
who grew up first
generation, do they
have-- I know another
friend of mine
also is in the
Bollywood industry
from [INAUDIBLE] school.
But what do you think of the--
does it help you or doesn't it?
BENNY DAYAL: Well, my
teachers were from there.
My dance teachers were from
[INAUDIBLE], music teachers
from [INAUDIBLE].
So what I learned are from
my teachers and my teachers
[? would read. ?]
So I think [INAUDIBLE]
has nothing to do with it.
It's what the teachers
will teach you
what you have to know.
And I must say, [INAUDIBLE]
the school that we were in
was also like [INAUDIBLE]
we were pretty competitive
and it really brought
the best out of us.
Like, if you see
[INAUDIBLE] was--
he [? talked ?] the
[INAUDIBLE] in science.
And he knew [INAUDIBLE].
Like, no, Joseph [INAUDIBLE]
so if you look at [? Nichol, ?]
[? Nichol ?] was not
just an academic person.
He was into
declamation, elocution.
He was into quizzing.
He was into [? mind ?] mental
quiz and he used to do music.
He was in drama.
He went to school
[? band ?] drama.
And he was also into sports.
He used to play cricket.
He used to have me on
[? his ?] cricket team.
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: But
what I'm saying is
that he was the head
boy of our school
and he also-- he was
actually the example
of a student being the
head boy and academically
doing extremely well.
It was-- no, I'm so proud of my
school and my [INAUDIBLE] mates
and my juniors and everybody.
So we were a pretty
competitive school,
and you know-- [? and ?]
actually made us effortlessly
to be cool.
No, I'm just joking.
I'm just joking.
INTERVIEWER: Is
there [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: So I'm just
asking [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: Yes, so we have
[INAUDIBLE] great teachers
who-- not only in school, but
in extracurricular activities
and stuff like that.
So it was good guidance
and really amazing time.
That's exactly why probably.
But yeah, we have to work hard.
This industry is not--
it's sort of the joke.
You have to get on
top of your game
and you have to really be
focused on what you do and try
and be an innovator.
I think innovation is the
key to success always.
INTERVIEWER: Asking [INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: I'm a [INAUDIBLE].
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
[? senior. ?]
BENNY DAYAL: [INAUDIBLE]
both fans of [INAUDIBLE]
is a great singer.
And if you like
[INAUDIBLE] sing,
I have a small story
about that [INAUDIBLE]
that is [INAUDIBLE] recorded
my voice for a [? database ?]
in the studio while he was
working with [INAUDIBLE].
And I [INAUDIBLE]
won't forget it.
He's a great guy and I wish
all amazing things for him.
INTERVIEWER: He's
a very humble guy.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
OK, so we're going
to talk about us now.
So, Google, what
are your thoughts?
What's Google done for
you, for the industry,
and-- so I live
in San Francisco.
And you look like you could
totally fit into San Francisco.
BENNY DAYAL: I agree.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so what do
you think about San Francisco?
What have you seen?
What have you done?
So we're going to
talk about us now.
BENNY DAYAL: I came
yesterday afternoon,
so I haven't done much.
I've only slept and woken up.
So-- and of course, we have
a beautiful class conference
for our event that's happening
tomorrow at the Jubilee Center.
But you know, Google
helps me in so many ways.
I just can't tell you how much.
And even tracing down
some people's names
and looking at history of
music, history of movies,
that's the feel that
I live and breathe.
So Google has always
been a huge instrument
to figuring out a lot
of things that we need
to-- especially as musicians.
And we need new equipment
and lots of things
and Google has been
so, so instrumental
in giving us-- paving
this and figuring out
[INAUDIBLE] things for
ourselves in music especially.
So whatever Google does,
I think it's fabulous
and I think Google
as a word, you just
can't use it as anything else.
It has become--
Google is Google.
And [INAUDIBLE] after
Google, I think nothing.
Nothing after Google.
Yeah, Google is
going to be forever.
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that you were rejected
many times by music directors.
So how did you [? face ?]
that rejection?
[INAUDIBLE]
BENNY DAYAL: See, that's
exactly what, you know?
It's really brought
out the best in me.
Somehow, I think it triggered
some nerve in me that just
made me want to do it more.
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE]?
BENNY DAYAL: I'm going
[INAUDIBLE] singer. [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm guessing you may have
[INAUDIBLE] actually looked
at them again.
So how did you overcome
any resentment?
BENNY DAYAL: I don't know.
I think when I met them, I had
a lot of hair and now I don't.
And so, yeah, so I
think that probably they
would have forgotten.
I don't know.
It's just-- everybody moves on.
And I think that's
the best thing
is just don't hold grudges.
And I did go back
to [INAUDIBLE] and I
did sing some beautiful
songs for that composer.
So that's that and
we'll leave it at that.
AUDIENCE: Awesome
thank you so much.
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE] Now,
guys, our program [INAUDIBLE]
is a very lucky [INAUDIBLE].
We would like to talk about this
concern of [INAUDIBLE] and you
guys should definitely
attend that.
It was [INAUDIBLE] will be
[INAUDIBLE] perform [INAUDIBLE]
performance [INAUDIBLE].
Great performance, [INAUDIBLE].
So I would let
[INAUDIBLE] call someone
to announce about
the [INAUDIBLE]
and when it's
[? going to ?] happen.
So--
BENNY DAYAL: OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Hi, guys I'm
with Gig Gurus, [INAUDIBLE].
And we are very, very lucky and
privileged to be hosting Benny
here in the Bay Area.
We're doing a concert tomorrow
at this wonderful venue called
the Jubilee Center, it's
the first time there's ever
been a Bollywood concert.
And they also-- the venue
yesterday, they said
it's perfect acoustically.
It's meant for this
kind of a concert.
Right, guys?
Yep, so it's going to
be a beautiful concert.
You heard Benny D here, but you
would see the [? functuation ?]
in motion tomorrow.
So we really urge you
to get your tickets.
We have a special
offer for Googlers.
Especially [? Yanit ?]
spoken to me
before we have a special code.
Google, if you use it, you
get a special discount.
I think [? Yanit ?] has
already propagated that.
So please do come
to the concert.
We'd love to see you all there
and help get the word out.
You heard [INAUDIBLE].
You should see him move, dance,
and we're like really, really
excited to see him out there.
And it's all for
a good cause too.
We're giving back
to a few charities
here in the Bay Area, three
beneficiary organizations.
So please do join us tomorrow.
We'd love to see you all there
and you can get your tickets
at giggurus.events--
G-I-G-G-U-R-U-S .events.
INTERVIEWER: Awesome.
So, thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
Would you like to say
a few words in the end?
Or--
BENNY DAYAL: Yeah, thank you.
Thank you so much for
taking out your time.
I'm sure you all have
a lot of work to do.
And you guys are smiling
I'm sure [? I'm ?] very
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm sure you're all
very happy to work here.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It really means a lot.
Thank you to Ahmed.
Ahmed, thank you so
much for having us over.
You've been very,
very kind to us.
And thank you all for
taking of your time
and coming and talking to me.
I'm really, really
thrilled and really
happy to be here in the Bay
Area and looking forward
to all of you coming
for my concert tomorrow
because this is what
I want to say also.
This is my first ever solo
concert in the United States
of America.
So [INAUDIBLE] and
I will [INAUDIBLE]
seeing some of the
most amazing composers
that I've worked with
when I come here.
But today, I am so thankful
to all those composers
for giving me such a
beautiful body of work.
And then I can showcase
my own concert.
So it will be really
special if all of you
come and you tell your
friends about this.
That's all I'm going to say.
And thank you, thank you,
thank you a million times,
more than any YouTube hits.
But thank you guys so much.
It's been really
special and God has
been very kind to all of us.
And that's about it.
Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: That
is all [INAUDIBLE].